auto requests to do a video on the
various methods to clean up ac from
surge protectors to filters to power
cords
so today i thought i'd do a video on
on this device from ps audio called the
noise harvester
ac cleaner and uh it's a little device
it looks a little bit larger than a
ac charger for your phone uh it has no
connections other than
a couple of ac prongs so you just plug
it into
an ac outlet that is next to the
whatever is powering the rest of your
audio coping and
as a parallel device is supposed to
filter out
that noise costs 99.
and if you read the description
it says that it collects the noise
from the ac line and then it discharges
it into a this little led
light over here that will blink every
time it's finished charge
uh charging that basically collecting
that much noise
it discharges it um no puzzle somebody
would say that's a good thing because
whenever you do a sudden thing
that can cause more uh disturbance
to a circuit than a gradual one
so the and that led blinks pretty fast
many times a second so
uh you know if this thing is aiming to
do its job gently uh
i don't know that that's the right thing
but it's a masterful
uh marketing in that a lot of times
these filters
you can't see them do anything and you
have to take it on faith that they're
doing something
this one actually has a light it's
reassuring and
it blinks and tells you that it's
getting rid of some noise that is
collecting
it does run warm by the way so it's
doing something and it's using power
so uh many times people say well these
devices can't be measured this one
actually is pretty easy to measure
the filtering that it has is independent
of voltage
it's a frequency domain filter if you
will so
i decided to treat it as if it's an
audio device
and uh or generic filter and i set up my
audio precision
either having this input going to its
output and just measuring itself with
nothing in between
or sticking this device in the middle
and
uh by doing that we can actually see
what effect it has
in the in a band that we're measuring so
the audio analyzer is set up to measure
up to 200 kilos
so well above audible band to get you
know measure what's happening
above audible band if there's any truth
to uh
stuff above 20 killers mattering i first
measure the analyzer itself to make sure
the cabling that i had for this
fixture doesn't affect anything and
indeed it doesn't
the other precision is just dead
accurate from
zero to 200 kilohertz no variation in
frequency response
as soon as i plug in the noise harvester
it actually make quite a bit of
difference you can see that it
starts filtering around 500 hertz and it
goes down
20 db or so there's some peaking in here
there's a resonance probably
and then it continues i'm filtering some
more so by 200 kilos you have 40 db of
attenuation so uh
this is shocking usually these things
don't do anything at all you can't
measure
and this one is measurable indeed and
if you read the spec it actually says
that it filters from 500 there's on i
forget where it says that but
so it seems like there's some truth to
what this device says is doing it's
actually doing that uh question is does
it matter
um just because you filter things
doesn't mean that
you've done what needs to be done so
for the next measurement i take ac mains
and it's high voltage obviously you
don't want to just bring that in and
measure it
blows up the analyzer so i just put it
in the step down transformer
and uh then on the other side it's the
same
response more or less but now it's noise
uh it's lower voltage so we can measure
it
and uh i zero out the uh mains at 60
hertz so this first spike that you see
in here is
is the only wanted thing uh but then we
see that the spectrum of
of mains uh uh over here it's got tons
of
distortion uh power companies sine wave
is clean
but it's not instrument grade clean i
can actually look at this uh
distortion plus noise and is almost
three percent
so without plugging in the noise
harvester that's what it is
i plug in the harvest there same
percentage distortion
why because if you look in here what are
the worst
uh spikes that we don't want out of our
ic mains are these harmonics
um you know this is 60 hertz is our main
then there's 180 hertz and
and so forth odd harmonics and none of
these are filtered because as i showed
you this thing doesn't do any filtering
until it gets to 500 hertz
so but unfortunately for us
most of our problems are two five or six
other thirds
so where we care about cleaning things
up it doesn't clean
you might say well how about above that
does it clean those well
if you squint the red is with the
harvester plugged in
you can see there's a tiny tiny tiny bit
of
reduction maybe but essentially it let
the bulk of all this garbage come
through why because
it's not capable of applying a lot of
filtering
a paper towel can filter things if you
pour water over it but if i
throw rocks on it you can't can't handle
that so
just because something's a filter
doesn't mean it's able to filter
anything you throw out it has to be
designed for that application
and indeed this thing is not able to
take out all this energy if it
wanted to take out all of this energy
you could build such a filter
it would be expensive as heck it'd be
large should be heavy and
chew up a lot of power because there's a
lot of power in here
but obviously this little device can't
do that
so um from the point of view of
of what he thinks is doing it is doing
that but that little led
uses so little power that what it
discharges after like i don't know one
tenth of a second
you know if it's just enough to light a
little led that's not material amount of
uh
noise to to get rid of that of course
assumes that
this is what is in your audio equipment
it is not we convert ac to dc and the
first thing we do is
filter the heck out of it so inside the
audio device we don't see these things
anyway
but uh we'll get to actually testing
real audio devices but
as far as the principle of what the
device does and our testing methodology
100 were able to quantify this device
measure its effect things that they
should demonstrate and
put up as evidence we're able to do that
so there's no mystery in here this is
not like
uh interconnect or speaker cable where
you can't measure anything but
it makes this for uh amazing
improvements here we can actually
quantify 100 what the device does
uh it just doesn't seem like it's doing
anything useful
if you look at the sine waves themselves
with or without the um
the noise harvest you can actually see
that the sine wave is distorted these
tops over here are flattened
they're not a pure nine sine wave so a
lot of times distortion is too low to
see
there see its effect in the time domain
which is what this is the
oscilloscope display but here the rac
main is
dirty enough that indeed we can see this
distorted
and the red one which is with ps audio
you can see it's the same thing it it's
not able to change
you know what's visibly distorted
continues to be visibly distorted and
visibly noisy so all the stuff that they
claim
to have gotten rid of uh is not visible
in frequency domain
it's not visible in in time domain
indeed we see that the problem remains
but uh let's uh see what the effect is
on real devices
on ac mains which we measure some effect
given how sensitive our instrumentation
is first test was my audio
analyzer heck if i can improve his
performance let's do that
so i have the audio precision plugged in
and it's measuring itself and it's
getting this incredibly good
sign out of 123.5 db so it's a very
zoomed scale and i let it run over time
and you can see how
stab rock stable this analyzer is
measuring itself the two channels are
red and blue
and then i plug in the noise harvester
and as soon as i plug it in
the light on it is blinking so it's
doing what it thinks is doing
but can you even see a difference in the
response of this analyzer
no neither is generator nor is analyzer
change one iota
if i change anything we would see some
some indication something's happening
here
and this is a sum of noise and
distortion and nothing's happened
whatsoever
and i unplug it then and we don't see an
effect there either so you might say
well this is an expensive
piece of equipment so obviously it has
very clean power
let's look at consumer products so at
that time that i tested this i had some
other products on my desk
so this is a topping a90 it's a
preamplifier
headphone amp and it's a 500 device so
it's not 28
000 again the same test and look at how
good this device is by the way it's
almost as good as my essential as good
as my analyzer
and uh plug it in
unplug now the darn thing happened it's
a little box so it's not some giant
thing
so well maybe that's also too good let's
go to something lower so at that time i
had the
nice jds labs atom deck it's a 99
deck and right away we see how sensitive
this test is
uh the stack by itself is actually
changing its uh
noise profile and and or distortion
profile so
it does have something wrong with it uh
if you will though
practically from 109 to 109.5 so
definitely not a practical problem but
i'm just showing you the power of the
instrumentation if there's something
there
this thing can tease it out and it is
indeed teasing it out
unfortunately for ps audio noise
harvester i'll plug it in
the same variations are there i take it
out
continues on as if nothing happened and
this thing has a little external
um ac adapter that you plug in
and uh and brings that ac
into the device from what i recall so if
you cleaned up that ac
surely that makes a difference it does
not make a difference at all
and uh there's always this uh
well i'll come back to that in a second
so um
then i i uh took a [ __ ] modi to uber
deck
uh [ __ ] these days makes extremely good
devices
good tax and preamps and what have you
at the time though they
had a few years ago they didn't have as
good a product so
i use them as an example of something
that is noisier
and to not as much of a state of the art
as the other products
and see if they make a difference and
again noise harvested plugged in
unplugged even at 94 db where noise is
an issue now
um nothing happened but the ps audio
harvest they're blinking saying i'm
getting rid of noise for you i'm getting
stuff you don't want no
um a lot of people who believe in these
vices immediately say
i don't care about these graphs i don't
understand them anyway and they don't
mean anything to you i use my ears
well i have ears how to use mine so i
went ahead and uh
my adi2 version uh ada2 deck is thousand
dollar
professional deck and i use my ether cx
headphone
and uh i'll listen to my music and i
would take the noise harvester plug it
in
and unplug it plug it in unplug it it's
beautiful thing as far as testing
because
you don't have to disturb your setup
it's just a thing you plug into the same
ac outlet
adapter or power strip as your device so
it doesn't interrupt music so if it's
going to
make a difference it would be pretty
easy to hear because
instantaneous is effect and uh
there's absolutely no difference there's
none
i mean this is revealing of the product
as a test as you can get
far more revealing that what a lot of
people use for
excuse me testing and there wasn't
anything else so
yes people will say that it as soon as
they plug in
great things happen as some other
members send me three of them once with
one of his decks
to test and i did very careful a b
test with it at the time too and even
three of them made no difference
whatsoever
so but people say well everybody raves
about these things you're the only one
who doesn't i actually
found the review of it online or this
guy said it absolutely did nothing for
him
you can go and uh watch it so it's not
just me
this is although this is an exception to
a rule most people will get one of these
things plug it in
and then spend more time listening for
differences and when they do that
as i've explained in other videos your
brain changes mode of operation starts
to pay attention more
and here's more detail or here's more
fidelity basically when you're paying
attention
than when you're in lean back enjoyment
mode and uh
whenever you're testing something you're
not testing in the way you use it
in everyday music system you're testing
in an analytical way with your ears
and your motor operation changes and
under unless you can hide whether the
device is plugged in or not
you will get in this cadence of thinking
i plugged it in and i listened and i
heard more detail when i unplug it
you're just going to program yourself
into thinking that if x gone
it's just hard to i know everything
about that effect by the way
and i can't avoid it myself so even i
could fall victim to that
knowledge of the phenomenon does not
protect you
in that regard so you've got to have
somebody else plug and unplug it
have a loved one sometime plug it in
sometimes unplug it 10 nights in a row
when you come home
don't look you know have it be hidden
that's where there's plug in there you
make a log
whether it's plugged in or not plugged
in plugged in or not plugged in
and your loved one will also make a log
of whether they did or did not
unplug it and at the end of 10 days
compare notes
if you get 10 out of 10 i'll bow about
your
abilities to hear supernatural things um
because
there's basically nothing in here so uh
bottom line there is an element of truth
to this device
it does what it does the flaw in it is
that
it doesn't solve the problem the problem
with ac
mains if you're just using ac mains
as is is this spikes in audio equipment
we don't deal with ac mains we bring in
ac and the first thing we do is convert
it to dc
and when we convert it dc we then filter
it
if we don't filter it it will actually
be not be a
dc so filtering is required to be part
of dc and many dax and audio products
have a switching power supply
and they convert it into dc switch it
high frequency and then convert it back
to
uh dc again so you're so far
removed from that process that you can
tweak all your one and ac mains
anybody designing audio equipment or any
kind of electronics equipment
knows that ac mains is dirty so of
course we don't
we know about this and we deal with it
or we couldn't have performance
this good out of a 500 device if you
allowed any of that
three percent noise to come into this uh
amplifier
it just would destroy its performance
this amplifier gives his
fantastic performance because first
thing it has a filter and
filtering is cheap i mean you know and
by the way
filtering in dc at low voltage is dirt
cheap
chatter filter mains uh you know 150
300 volts or more peak voltage
it's extremely expensive so why in the
heck would you want to filter
in ac domain of course we're going to
filter in dc domain because we have
little voltages a capacitor
that's rated for 10 volts is a heck of a
lot cheaper than a capacitor is rated
for 300 volts 400 volts 500 volts and
those caps can also be
quite tiny whereas the components that
are used for high voltage are massive
you had a small capac value capacitor at
400 volts
it'd be a giant thing and so it's stupid
to go and try to clean up ac
when we already cleaned up in dc it's
cheaper
easier and it's already done for you you
don't need to spend a hundred dollars on
this
take the hundred dollars go have nice
dinner with it uh buy some more music
something else to enjoy then plug this
in and watch the led blink thinking
oh my god it's improving my sound it is
not even if you think it is improving
your sound
that effect will wear off later on and
then you'll be out looking for that next
tweak
to get that high again that something's
happening
okay that's all i have for you on this i
have other power
product uh videos coming but uh i
thought we cover
this little noise harvester okay see you
in the future video bye-bye